hello everyone and welcome back to book
club
lots of people showing up from all over
the world from the UAE Costa Rica
Denmark Brazil Greece Arizona Ohio Vail
Lebanon I just love Pittsburgh we go
from Lebanon to exotic Pittsburgh I love
it Texas I just love how many people
join Spain hello its I love how it's
becoming a global thing for all of us
thanks for coming back we tried to
adjust the time so that even more people
could join in how to stay up too late so
thank you for being here India also as
many of you may know we started book
club near the beginning of kovat because
we were all physically separated and I
wanted to do something where we could
maintain our social bonds and the whole
idea was not necessarily about reading a
book but finding an excuse to get on the
phone with people to get on zoom' with
people and to talk and talk about
something that's not the news or kovat
or something like that and that's why we
started book club it was about us doing
things together so thank you for forming
your book clubs and and being a part of
it a few changes this time we're now on
three platforms YouTube LinkedIn and
Facebook also new we started a book club
Facebook group and so all book club
discussion and you can watch it there
and all that good stuff so if you want
to join that meet other people in the
book club again this is about doing
things together you can go do that I had
such an amazing time we weren't planning
on doing more book clubs to be honest we
were gonna do start with why because I
had to reread the book and I figured
invite other people to read it with me
but I'll be honest with you I had so
much fun and after each one I was so
inspired that we decided to do it again
and instead of doing the books in order
we decided to read the infinite game
mostly because I think that the message
of the infinite game and the lessons in
the infinite game are so valuable and
valid to everything that's going on in
the world the black lives matter
movement Cove it'd just just the fact
that we've become more connected as a
planet I think because we're all going
through
many similar things I thought the
mentality of the infinite game was
really important to discuss can't
believe it's July already it feels like
we started the last book club in April
if you can believe it what else I have
my notes here I think that's everything
for future book clubs if you want to
send questions you can always send them
to book club at simon Sinek comm
obviously we're also gonna do live
questions here okay
well let's get going so let me give you
a little history of this book so it's
based on the philosophy of by a
philosopher named James cars' somebody
gave me his book many many years ago
called finite infinite games and it's
this wonderful little kooky little book
it's this treatise about these two these
two types of games and it really
challenged my way of thinking that we
are these players and infinite games and
I realized so much of what we learn in
leadership even just how to manage our
own careers we're getting bad advice
everything's about winning and being
number one and I realize that's not what
life is life is not about a finish line
life is of a journey life is not about
just a series of destinations life is
this ongoing thing and I think one of
the reasons that I discovered that one
of the reasons I think we mess up
leadership a little bit and sometimes
create more complication in our lives is
simply because of our mindset and so I
be I was using dr. Carson's work and a
lot of the other work that I was doing
and at some point realized I wanted to
write more about how do we actually
learn an infinite mindset and that's
what the infinite game is all about I'll
tell you a quick little story because I
had the opportunity to meet dr. Carr's
recently he's 87 years old he's amazing
he's sprightly he's funny he's engaging
and I asked him of course I had to ask
him how did you come up with the
infinite game and he was explained to me
that in the 1970s game theory was all
the rage all everybody was talking about
it and a lot of these mastermind groups
were formed to discuss game theory if
any of you have ever heard of the
prisoner's dilemma that came out of one
of these masks
many groups in the 1970s and so it was
like philosophers and mathematicians and
economists who would join up and talk
about these things and dr. cars was
invited and he was astonished that all
they were doing is talking about winning
and losing winning and losing and so he
raised his hand and said what about
playing because even the prisoner's
dilemma is about being the winner and so
he got this idea stuck in his head about
what about the play and he went home and
he started to notice patterns and he saw
his kids when they would play ping-pong
he had three sons when they would play
ping-pong
there was always fighting there was
always paddles being slammed down if
somebody lost there was always
accusations of somebody cheating and it
was always sort of a bit aggressive but
when his kids were doing something
creative like Lego or drawing it was
quiet people would come and go
throughout the day and it would just go
on and on and on and he started to
recognize the value of play rather than
the value of just attempting to win and
recognized that this idea of playing is
actually more important than anything
else what I call an infinite mindset he
calls play and so when you start a
business or go through your career or go
through your life it's about the ply
it's about the joy of the game that we
come and go and sometimes things go well
and sometimes they don't we can have
finite objectives but it's this ongoing
sort of thing and so it was so wonderful
to learn the origin story I thought what
I would do before I start answering
questions first of all a couple little
shout outs my folks are on here I have
to say hi to them my mom my dad I also
have to say hello to the Dakota potato
peel pie and literary society you guys
have been freaking loyal from the get-go
so thanks for being here tell you a
couple little things I marked some
chapters and please post your questions
in the chat and I can get to some of
those so it was fun to reread the book
obviously it's not been as all along as
start with Y but it was fun to reread
there's a couple things that really
stood out me that really struck me
that I really appreciate it and it
reminded me of sort of how to even
approach my own career and there was one
one phrase here
what on page 19 that says a finite
minded leader uses the company's
performance to demonstrate the value of
their own career an infinite mindedly
an infinite minded leader uses their
career to enhance the long-term value of
the company and I love this I really
love this idea of using performance of
our company to show how good we are
versus showing up every day to help to
help the company be better which means
help the customer get something more
help our employees go our colleagues go
home feeling more fulfilled that it's
the ideas showing up with a giving
mentality versus a taking mentality and
that just really struck me the number of
fancy CEOs who tell you how great they
were because of how their company
performed like their company as a
standard they use to prove to prove
their worth more specifically and I'm
happy to discuss this further if you
like I was really struck by some of the
the explanations of what it just causes
especially the social movement that's
going on now with black lives matter and
the social movement that is growing on
how it's how it can grow how it can
succeed and be and really take hold and
be sticky and I wrote about how a Just
Cause must be these five things it's
it's like a test it has to be for
something it has to be optimistic and
affirmative it's about where we're going
not where we're coming from it has to be
inclusive open to all those who would
like to contribute so the question is is
how do we make an invitation there can
be different opinions on how we can
advance a cause and the whole point is
to get different opinions because though
we can differ on how we think it works
the point is we all want is we want to
get as many people as possible focused
in the same direction I think a great
example is politics I'll use America
just because I live here
one of the things that I think we forget
is the difference between the political
parties should be the intention is that
we
on the founding principles of the nation
that all people are created equal
endowed with unalienable rights amongst
which include life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness the question is how
are we going to get there and the
political parties have different
opinions about how we provide these
unalienable rights to all people that's
the discussion and that's why the
parties go in and out of power depending
on the time because politics change and
opinions change and cultures change and
perspectives change and so we may favor
one strategy over another depending on
the time but the real debate should be
about how we get there not about where
we're going and I think where politics
becomes destructive is where we start
debating what the whole point is that
was established for us already that's
the foundation of the nation the debate
is simply how do we get there
it has to be inclusive that all people
in all parties have a say
service-oriented we've talked about this
one that the primary benefit has to be
others yes we can reap benefit from our
own careers we can make a good living we
can we can have our ideas spread that's
fine we can be received notoriety for
ideas these things are fine but the
primary the objective word is the
operative word here is primary must be
for the good of others service a service
mentality we are social animals were
tribal animals and this is how we build
community we trust each other when we
trust that the people in our community
actually are thinking about us and
caring about us this is why service
orientation really matters it builds
trust if we have a selfish orientation
we put ourselves at the center of the
equation we destroy trust resilience it
has to be able to endure and it has to
be idealistic and I think this is a very
important thing right now which is these
ideals that we have will never be
perfect we will never get it right but
the whole point of any social movement
or any national experiment or any nation
or any career or any life is that we're
advancing further and further down a
path knowing full well that we'll never
get to the ideal state that we hope to
one day I really love this idea big and
idealistic and unachievable I think
that's important and to recognize that
progress gets made fast and
slow and sometimes there are steps back
but the point is to continuously point
Ford's this is what inspires us this is
what motivates us to show up every day
ok that's my little preamble who's just
I really enjoyed reading this I have to
say it was really fun to read it again
especially given the context of the
world we're living in now to read about
the Just Cause reminded me and it was as
relevant now as it was when I wrote it
let's do some questions ok first
question from the International book
club Julia and Sonya can a person have
an infinite mindset in their private
life though act finite minded in their
business life if so could the main
drivers to act with different mindsets
in different environments ok you can
have infinite mindset and a finite mind
said everywhere
the the the important thing is not to
create to create them as in opposition
they're not on opposite sides of a
seesaw it's not you have an infinite
mindset and I have a finite mind said
that's not quite how it is it's that the
finally the infinite mindset is the
context within which the finite mind the
finite things can exist it's not the
absence of finite it's the it's the the
purpose for those finite things so for
example it is a false belief that an
infinite mindset is simply set a series
of finite games win this game win the
next game win the next game win the next
game win the next game a that's tiring
and be you never find fulfilment and you
always feel like you're playing an
aggressive game in politics or business
if all it is is about get the next bonus
get the next bonus get the next bonus
it's just it just it just doesn't work
and you accidentally weaken the
organization so the and I think I'd
wrote about this the analogy we have to
think about is health a lifestyle right
so it's about what does it take to be
healthy you have to sleep you have to
eat well you have to exercise you have
to maintain your personal relationships
probably a list of 30 or 40 other things
you can never do we can never do all of
these things you know at a high level
all the time it just doesn't work that
way it's too difficult and so we're
we're
trying to do it we're constantly trying
to live a healthy life
you can absolutely we can absolutely
have finite goals within that I want to
lose X amount of weight by X date right
totally fine
same in business we want to hit that
goal that number by that date totally
fine and if you hit that goal you're
excited and you're happy but here's the
challenge you have to keep working out
for the rest of your life the game
hasn't ended same in business you hit
the goal then what you have to do it
again because there's no finish line and
what happens if you miss the goal
nothing nothing happens like you're
still healthier now than you were when
you started exercising and you if you
keep on the path you'll hit your goal in
another month or two same in business
and so yes of course you can have finite
objectives in business just like you're
gonna find out objectives in your own
life but the question is what is this
finite objective advancing and so I I'm
very uncomfortable with us creating this
like I'm infinite in my personal life
and finite in business because that
that's I think this sort of work-life
imbalance craziness which is the goals
that I hit are to advance what that's
the just cause that's what those find
out objectives should be their way
points along the way ok that was a long
answer good question we're from Lauren
McCormack ok related question from Lori
McCormack have you applied the infinite
mindset to other aspects of your life
outside the workplace if so how has it
benefited you the answer is yes the more
I've learned about this I've tried to
embrace the infinite mindset in all
aspects of my life I've I try very hard
not to distinguish between my work life
and my home life it's me the reason my
friends love me is the same reason my
colleagues love me it's me and so an
infinite mindset means I bring the same
just cause to my personal life I just
look for different ways to advance it so
for example if my Just Cause is to
create a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do in my work it's about
the talks I gave the books I write the
the classes that we offer on our website
the t-shirts that we that we we offer as
well
all to help advance a particular mindset
this is as much as a reminder to me as
it is a message like I'm a walking
billboard and in my personal life I do
the exact same thing I want to make sure
that my friends have a safe space to
call me and say I'm struggling I'm
having a hard time and it's happened
with kovat and and black lives matter
there's been a lot of uncomfortable
difficult conversations where people
sometimes maybe have felt really
vulnerable but the point is is we called
each other and we talked we didn't keep
that information to ourselves and I
think that infinite mindset really
helped it also helps me manage
difficulty things go badly things go
wrong I have fights with friends
sometimes I disagreements professionally
things go sideways and I have to try and
remember this as a point in the journey
and the goal is to try and make
decisions good decisions and difficult
decisions and be cognizant of the the
things I get wrong because I understand
this journey is long and I'm still
trying to get over there
so absolutely I've tried to maintain an
infinite mindset in my personal life and
it has been really helpful it's helped
me keep much more grounded and keep
things in context
Maria Mastro de casa did I get that
right master de casa yeah Maria master
de casa when you are playing the
infinite game are you able to authentic
enough be authentic enough to ask for
help and guidance if so what would it
look like to ask for help when you're in
a position of leadership such a good
question
I think when we play with a finite
mindset it's actually harder to ask for
help because we position ourselves as
winners or or and especially when you
reach a position of leadership now we
think we have to have all the answers we
have to be right if you maintain this
infinite mindset that it's a journey of
Education and learning and that your
that no matter what job you have every
day you're learning to do that job if
you're in customer service every day
you're learning how to deal with
customer service in a better way because
you may have difficult people on the
other end of a phone or across a counter
and you're learning every day how to be
talking to people as you reach a
position of leadership every day you're
trying to be a better leader and I think
one of the the biggest things about
being a great leader is having the
courage to make difficult decisions but
also the courage to ask for help it's
essential that leaders have peer groups
people they can call and say I'm
struggling it's one of the most
important things to me I have a group of
friends it's informal people I love and
care about and every now and then we
will call each other and ask for help
and here's the amazing thing that I
learned that it only took one of us to
do it first until the other one did it
and so I had these friendships where we
all sort of had all the answers we've
all had our opinions and we all had our
big egos and all of this stuff and their
big personalities and I remember one
time I called a good friend of mine and
said I'm struggling I said I need your
advice
and from that point on he always calls
me and says I'm struggling I need your
advice and I think this is wonderful it
only to be the leader we call you leader
not because you're in charge we call you
leader because you went first and so the
willingness to be vulnerable in the
willingness to ask for help is one of
the factors that makes you a leader and
creates an environment in which others
will do the same great question Nina
Myers hi Nina what is the best way to
teach an infinite mindset to someone
especially in a way that they won't get
defensive I think if we're it's so the
word teach is where I'm getting hung up
on right I like the word share I like
the word introduced I like the word
invite and someone will get defensive
not necessarily because what we're
trying to share with them more likely
people get defensive because of the
manner in which we share it with them
so for example if we think that they're
two finite driven and we decide we want
to teach them about infinite they're
probably going to get defensive because
they think we're attacking the way in
which they do things and we might be and
so what I'm a great believer in is
talking about my experience which is I
want to share something that has
helped me a great deal it's called the
infinite game and has profoundly changed
the way I see the world and then I
simply talked about what the theory is
this is the great thing about dr.
Carson's work the definition of finite
infinite games you can explain in 30
seconds and people understand it and you
can see people's wheels start turning
and then I relate it to myself and I
realized that when I was waking up every
day to like beat the competition or be
number one I realized this is why it was
causing me so much stress and sometimes
even hurting my relationships or or
hurting innovation whatever it is and
then since I've embraced this infinite
mindset I realize how helpful it was
anyway I just wanted to share how this
has helped me and it's not an imposition
so I have found that the way to get
people to here is to not talk about them
because that we don't know what how
they're feeling or what what place
they're and in their lives even though
we're well-intentioned they may take it
the wrong way and get defensive I find
it's a great way to talk about me when
introducing new ideas to people I think
would appreciate them also I believe in
talking to people who want to hear what
I have to say people who ask me who do
you talk to and I'm like whoever wants
to listen if somebody's resistant I just
move on remember I we talked about this
in the in the start with why book club
was I'm I'm a devotee to the law of
diffusion of innovations and I really
try not to waste too much breath with
people on the right side of the law of
diffusion because it's a hell of a lot
of effort for very little gain and
rather I want at least talk to people
who are open they may not agree but
they're at least open to an idea that's
different to theirs so don't force
anyone let's see
Lisa Erickson as I think of myself in my
career how can I have an infinite
mindset when it feels like to be
successful I need to focus on the finite
mindset oh boy you nailed it how would
you suggest adopting an infinite mindset
for an individual contributor a role ok
this is one of the challenges this is
one of the reasons I wrote this book
which is so many of us dare I say most
of us are going to work in environments
at companies that quite frankly they're
only playing the finite game and all of
the incentives all of the pressures all
of the instructions we're getting are
finite finite finite finite
so what are we supposed to do will we be
the leaders we wish we had and though we
can't change the incentive structures of
the organization and though we can't
change the reward structures in how our
our leaders may recognize us and tell us
good work we can change how we show up
everybody else and we can we can start
to recontextualize our own work which is
I'm going to use my job to learn how to
be a better leader I'm going to learn to
take care of the people around me and
I'm going to talk about how their work
benefits the people around them in other
words you treat your team whether you're
the leader or not whether you I should
say this whether you're the authority or
not because you can be the leader even
if you're not the authority whether you
have the authority or not you treat your
little team as if you're the company and
I've seen this happen where you have
these wonderful teams that end up
becoming much higher performing because
the team trusts each other they care
about each other to become more
innovative a close minded company a very
finite minded company usually just
leaves that team alone because their
numbers are good and if you have
curiosity at the top they're interested
in why retention is better Morales
higher performance is better and they
come over and say what are you doing and
eventually one of those people will get
either promoted or moved out of the
group to another group and they take
everything they've learned and so to
show up with an infinite mindset means
I'm gonna teach good leadership to the
people I work with I'm gonna serve as an
example because each of those people has
the potential to be a leader somewhere
else I'm gonna fill the organization
with great leaders that in five years
ten years fifteen years when the people
who who have the authority now or have
gone and left we will we will take over
the infinite mindset is also about
patience which is I'm doing this for a
higher calling I'm doing this to have a
positive impact and I may not be around
to see the result that's the hard part
about having an image of mindset think
about in terms of a social movement all
of the founders of the women's suffrage
movement all of them were dead before
women's suffrage was passed before we
gave the vote to women right think about
that for a second they devoted their
lives to something that they never saw
the result happened and yet they died
proud because they could see and feel
the momentum because of the people
around them that they had inspired who
they knew would carry the torch one
they were gone that's what you do inside
your organization find people that you
can pass the torch on to Daniel rs.20
yes so he didn't he says he I don't mean
to be Bohr morbid but how do you play
with the infant mindset when the reality
is we born we have a life we die we have
a finite life we are finite players in
the infinite game and that's the
important thing to remember which is
though our lives are finite life is
infinite and we are part of Continuum's
we we were born of parents and whether
we have our own children we definitely
will have lots of friends and
relationships throughout our lives and
we will have impact and so we have a
choice remember there's three things we
always consider you don't get to choose
the rules of the game right life is an
infinite game with us or without us born
die life continues life doesn't care
right it continues with us without us
we can choose if we want to play in the
game in this case you don't get a choice
you're born you're in unlike business
you can choose if you want to start a
business or not but the third thing is
we get to choose how we play the game
and so yes you can absolutely play life
the game of life with a finite mindset
and the way that looks is I'm gonna be
number one I'm gonna make every decision
as to what what will pay me more which
will get me more power which will get me
more influence I remember talking to a
guy who was it was a friend of was the
husband of my a friend of my sisters and
he was in a dark place in his career he
just lost his job and he wanted my
advice he wanted to help find that is
why and I got on the phone with him we
started talking and ice tried to find I
started asking him questions about tell
me a time in your career where you loved
what you were doing he could not think
of one he couldn't
think of one project one instance one
job he's ever had
that he loved being a part of and I
asked him how he chose his jobs in every
single time he changed jobs he was
because of the salary that was offered
to him when he graduated college he took
the first job that offered him the
highest salary he had competing offers
the second job he took the highest
salary the third job he took the highest
salary he only ever took jobs that paid
him more and now he was unbelievably
unhappy and had nothing to look back to
had very few relationships had very few
loyal relationships that he could call
upon because he was always selfishly
directed he had chosen to play with a
finite mindset it's a choice it usually
comes with a lot of health problems as
well creates more stress and all the
other health related things that come
with stress or we can choose to play
with an infinite mindset and what that
means is we live our lives with the
knowledge that we will die and we want
to leave this world our company our
families our friends in better shape
than when we found them I think about
that for a second that when when our
friends and family go to our funeral
they will stand and cry and talk about
that they would not be the person they
are today if it weren't for having you
in their lives and so many people think
about their legacies at the end of their
lives when they face their own mortality
that's the problem only when they face
their mortality do they start thinking
about legacy and giving and and giving
to charity and giving it all away why
not do that when you're 21 why not do
that when you're 18 why not live your
entire life thinking about your legacy
meaning what impact will we have in the
lives of others no one wants to be
remembered for the amount of money they
made no one wants on their tombstone the
last balance in their bank account or
the title on their business card we want
to be remembered for the impact we have
in the lives of others devoted mother
loving father that's how you live an
infinite life even though our lives are
finite
here's one from Todd Sidney Eric run and
sherry with our society's focus on our
law enforcement officers how do you see
us reframing our thought process not to
blame but to address complexity and
create changes for resolution such a
good question right now we're in a place
of anger and anger has to come out think
of it like having a fight with someone
you love
your spouse your boyfriend your
girlfriend a friend right where you have
a relationship it's sibling right you
have a relationship where there's no
getting out of this relationship and and
because there has been very bad
communication for so long that all of
the slights and all of the little things
that that noodled and needed us in these
relationships it happens at work
sometimes too we constantly somebody's
always cutting us off in a meeting
somebody's constantly interrupting us
and eventually one day we just start we
just lose it we slam my hand on the desk
and say will you just stop interrupting
me and there's a fight and there's anger
and then all it takes is one person
either party to listen and try to
understand where the anger is coming
from and then there's a dialogue and
then both parties start listening and
then you usually end up hugging and
being grateful and though you don't want
to go through that experience again you
are grateful that it happened because it
forced each party to listen and try to
understand the position of the other and
those friendships friendships and
marriages that have have been able to
navigate stress together and learn to
listen and hear each other are way
stronger as a result our society is
going through the same thing we have to
allow for the letting of the anger you
cuts when somebody slams their foot
their fists on the table the worst thing
we can do is say that's not gonna help
there's there's a process to this and
and and what it takes now is for people
to start to try and understand and
either party it can come from either
side you can come from law enforcement
it can come from the african-american
community come from the general
community come from people who've been
wronged people have it doesn't matter
come from anywhere where somebody says I
need to understand what you go through
because we will not find a solution
until we find common understanding and
for one group to say well I'm not going
first at their responsibility leadership
is about the courage to go first it
doesn't matter where the courage comes
from one party just needs to go first
one of the best examples I heard I did a
podcast with Maria Shriver and first of
all she's amazing but she was telling me
a story of an african-american woman who
is afraid of the police
who's deathly afraid of the police and
the way she addressed her fear was she
invited a group of police officers to
come into her home to have tea and to
talk and even though she has been
wronged and even though those in her
community have been wronged and suffered
as a result she was the leader she
didn't want to talk she didn't want to
tell them she wanted to listen this
started an amazing dialogue of
understanding this is what leadership
looks like in times of stress great
question and by the way this has to
happen until we start hearing each other
we live in a society especially because
of social media everybody loves to talk
social media is not a listening medium
it's a talking medium it's about
projecting and declaring and
broadcasting we even call it
broadcasting there's no mechanism to
listen nobody's ever read a comment from
somebody that posted on their feet and
went mmm that's a good point I think
I'll change my mind never in the history
of the world has that ever happened we
shout at each other we talk at each
other dialogue requires us to sit down
together in person or or over over it
over a zoom I guess in this modern day
and listen and try to talk try to listen
I mean try to hear okay josh Josh Fitz
how are you Shanna yes
[Music]
yeah so Josh was saying he has family
who are in law enforcement and I can
tell you right now that the morale in
law enforcement as you could imagine is
very very low and one of the challenges
we're gonna have is the lower morale
goes the more disconnected think about
in our own jobs what do you do when your
morale is really low you disconnect you
don't feel like doing your work you show
up and you do the minimum and that won't
help
and so what teaching an infinite mindset
to law enforcement I mean I think I've
had some conversations with law
enforcement and one of the best things
we can do first is have empathy hey man
how are you how you doing right it's not
a question of right or wrong it's not
qualitative it's not judgment
it's simply human but there's a human
being here we're just saying how are you
just as we would expect the opposite how
are you if you have african-american
friends how you doing same thing and
what that does is it allows for a safe
space it allows her a safe space to some
to allow someone to express themselves
rather than defend themselves because if
we show up with anger we showed with
attack guess what they're gonna dig in
their heels they're gonna put up a
barrier and they're gonna defend even if
they disagree with their own defense why
because they feel attacked and so what
we want to do is create that safe space
teaching the infinite Minds bed is about
infinite mindset is about creating that
safe space that simply allows them to to
say whatever they want to say and we
here without judgment we don't have to
agree with it we're just creating a
space and then when that vulnerability
comes out and and I've had these
conversations then what ends up
happening is these people in law
enforcement say we have a lot to do in
our profession we have to change things
we have to do things differently and
they'll start to tell you the things
that can be done and they start to
become allies and helpful because they
know what levers work and how the
culture works a lot better than the
outsiders we're creating allies and the
REA you create allies is just making
people feel heard we don't have to agree
or disagree it's just about creating a
safe space to feel heard so yes that
infinite mindset will definitely help
with your family that's in law
enforcement
okay Rodney Kurihara how do you play the
infinite game when your company the
executive leadership is firmly
entrenched in the finite game
hypothetically speaking there Rodney
also is their use for finite leaders
okay
so first of all let's call them finite
minded right because it's their mindset
no one is born this way right and it's
kind of a little bit like the question
we had before which is unfortunately our
society glorifies the finite mindedness
we glorify the people who cut costs and
and demonstrate the bottom line is great
at the expense at the great expense of
people or the longevity of the company
the average lifespan of a company in the
1950s was about 60 something years the
average lifespan now is about 18 years I
mean that's crazy in other words we have
done damage to our own companies because
the finite mindedness and so it goes
back to the answer I gave before which
is we cannot change the minds of people
who are who are more senior than us you
know if your CEO is three or four levels
above what are you gonna do you can't
change other people no number of
anonymously sent books will change their
mind please keep trying but it won't
work and so all we can do is take
responsibility for ourselves the only
thing that we can actually change is
ourselves we can't even change our own
circumstances we can only change our
reaction to the circumstances around us
and I'll go back to the answer I gave
some moments ago be the leader you wish
you had don't worry about the bus that's
finite minded worry about the team that
you can learn to be the great infinite
minded leader and that you can impart
that same education on your team and
create more leaders one of the primary
jobs of a leader is to make more leaders
and so look to the left and look to the
right and say these people these are the
ones that could be the future leaders
I'm gonna be a part of the solution
these the people that will eventually
replace that person who I know is gonna
retire get fired or die who's gonna
replace them let's build the bench now
all the low-level and middle management
folks now will eventually be the senior
leaders let's build our bench be a part
of building the bench like that women's
suffrage movement
the bench even if you aren't there to
see it happen it's about momentum and
the second question you ask is is there
a use for finite minded leaders of
course these are not good or bad it's
it's it's that finite minded leaders
have value as long as they understand
the context in which they're operating
like I'm I'm so head in the clouds that
if you left me to my own devices nothing
would ever get done you know and so I
need people around me who are much more
process driven and operationally driven
and sometimes the frustration we have
with each other is I'm all head in the
clouds and they're like Simon I just
need you to focus here and I think that
they're being so focused that they can't
see the forest for the trees my job is
to help them see the forest for their
trees their job is to try to see the
forest for the trees so they understand
the context within which all those
finite choices are being made the
biggest mistake we make is when we take
that find it minded personality and we
put them in a job that has to be
infinite minded and they are unwilling
or cannot adapt it's not it's not a fed
a complete that just because you were in
a finite mind a job an Operations job
and you're now in a in a visionary job
people that can adapt but it's hard if
you're a senior leader if you're 50
years old and 60 years old and I'm gonna
tell you now oh by the way everything
that made you successful and get to this
point by the way you have to abandon
that and learn a completely new mindset
because your job is different and it's
really hard to do especially because
they've been so successful with
everything they've been doing but if
you're an operator and you've been moved
into a visionary job that's exactly what
you have to do so do we have need for
finite minded personalities of course as
long as they're in partnership and
understand that there's a greater
context for the work that they're doing
ok let's take a question from over here
what do we have here
what books Juan Gonzales how are you
what books and themes do you have in the
oven you know i i i i don't want to i
don't do multi book deals because i
don't want to be forced to write a book
every book I've written I think is the
last one to be honest with you I will
only write a book if I think I have
something
shirring I I will tell you however I am
very interested in human relationships
these days I'm really interested in what
makes this work and not work why we get
along and why we don't get along
we're tribal animals you've heard me say
this before many of you have heard me
say this before we have an entire
section in the book shop called
self-help we have no section on the
bookshop called help others and I'm more
interested in building the help others
industry and contributing to the
self-help industry you know our nation
our society has over indexed on rugged
individualism and defining things like
money and and and and possessions as as
definitions of success and yet the
people who we admire and want to often
be more like are those who are willing
to sacrifice their interest for the good
of others I I like to point out that the
highest metal in our land the the
Congressional Medal of Honor first of
all this is I have so much respect for
the military and how they how they give
the Congressional Medal of Honor this is
the highest medal in the land we don't
give it to people who just had mission
success in fact very often we give it to
people who had mission failure but every
time we give the Congressional Medal of
Honor it's to recognize someone who is
willing to sacrifice their own life
whether they survived or not so that
someone else may survive we consider
that the the best thing a human being
can do and then we never say they won
the medal they say that they were
awarded the middle and I love that
subtle a tip of the hat to the infinite
mindset that the medal was awarded it
was not one it's an eye I just adore
that and so when you ask me what books I
have in the oven nothing specific but I
if I if you forced me to take a bet
it'll probably be something to do with
human relationships okay so the Matt
from Manchester as how do you start a
small business with an infinite mindset
example a small cafe
okay so the Just Cause that you have and
by the way you can have your own or you
can find someone else's I think we put
too much pressure on ourselves like
especially young people because we're
we're constantly asking what's your
vision what's your vision entrepreneurs
are constantly asked what's your vision
we all have to come up with a vision too
much pressure
not everybody's visionary not everybody
Steve Jobs only a small percentage of
people have the ability to literally
imagine a future that does not yet exist
we don't all have to have a vision we do
all have to find a vision that someone
else could have articulated a vision
that is incredibly inspiring to you and
you can take that vision and make it
your own this is what social movements
are about but it doesn't have to be
exclusive to social movements when
Martin Luther King said I have a dream
that dream became a lot of people's
dreams he was just one to articulate it
and help us see it and so whether you
have your own vision of the future or
you like someone else's my friend Bob
Chapman when you ask him what does your
company do he says we make great people
to do extraordinary things
he owns a manufacturing company it has
nothing to do with manufacturing it has
to do with the culture he's trying to
build he says we measure success by how
we touch the lives of the people we
interact with right so if you're
starting a cafe sometimes your product
can actually advance the cause that's
absolutely doable but maybe it's about
being culture you want to build maybe
you want to create an environment where
you believe that every person has an
opportunity and you want to give them
opportunity so the question is is where
you hiring from are you hiring
maybe ex-convicts who are struggling to
get their feet on the ground are you
hiring people that can't get a break or
maybe your vision is about creating a
place in which people feel inspired safe
and fulfilled in which case what culture
will you build and how will you pass
that on to your customers and your
employees it doesn't necessarily have to
be based on your product it can be B and
what you'll find is the way you show up
the way you advertise the way you
decorate the cafe the way you talk to
people Cafe Gratitude which is a place
in California they're all about optimism
and give
it's sort of wonderful ooey-gooey
hippie-dippie stuff and they're there
the names of their stuff on their menu
is like something's called beautiful
something's called inspiring something's
called passionate and the way that the
the waitstaff brings you your stuff I
remember the first time it happened I
didn't really understand and they put
down my tea and they said you were
beautiful here you know and I was like
whew
they were telling me that I ordered a
beautiful and here it was you know or
here's your passion and I just loved
that these little these little things
was the food good the food was fine
you know sometimes good at sometimes it
was very average but the way that they
showed up in their little cafe was made
me keep going back because I just like
going there anyway you get the point
Sara and Nicola the raft girls are you
RAF cause your Royal Air Force we're
over the moon you're back well thank you
very much I'm over the moon to be back
we found our wise but how do we find a
just cause okay I love that you found
your why as you know from going through
that process and if you've taken the
jump start your Y class you know what
it's like it's about going backwards
learning your Y is about looking for
patterns of behavior there is there are
consistent patterns in all of our lives
when we are at our natural best and it's
about identifying those patterns so that
we can be at our natural best more often
the Y's about the past are just causes
about the future so you say how do we
find a just cause as I said before have
you ever tried to put into words the
world you imagined go for a long walk
Sarah and Nicola go together and just
talk about the world you want to live in
just don't worry about writing it down
you can record it if you want I guess
but just talk about the world that you
want to live in and what perfect would
look like and try and come with specific
examples like what would a specific
example of work look like like talk
about it specifically you know how would
someone feel what would it look like
what you're starting to articulate is
vision right can you imagine it in your
mind's eye can you see what other people
cannot see or who are the people that
inspire you who are the authors or the
or the or the leaders the politicians or
the CEOs like there are people out there
who are who are speak
with with with with with great clarity
about the vision and if there's someone
who stands out and goes ah mmm I love
that I love that then make that cause
your own make that cause your own it's
it's finding doesn't have to be internal
finding can be external but have the
conversation a lot the way I was able to
articulate my vision came from lots and
lots of conversations and I would pick
things up from other people I remember
when I first met Bob Chapman as I talked
about a moment ago we would talk and Bob
would use words that I was like that's
really good I like that and I sort of
used them to inform my own vision and
there were people that inspired me that
I just I I put pieces together I put a
jigsaw puzzle together until it formed a
picture and I was able to describe the
picture that I saw you can do the same
doesn't have to happen immediately
it's a journey yeah so a lot of people
asking about the difference in a why
again a Just Cause is sorry a why is
objective and comes from the past it is
an origin story it's where we come from
a just cause is subjective it's about
the future and where we're going
but why comes from the past it informs
our values it informs who we are
everybody has a why it's our god-given
right we're born with it and you have
only one and it never changes your whole
life your Just Cause is entirely up to
you you can point your life in any
direction you want you can have them
even though you only have one why
because it comes from the past and it's
a build it's about building blocks you
can have multiple just causes you can
have one for church one for home one for
a career one for work there's probably
gonna be some overlap you can have one
just cause that informs everything but
one's about where we came from one's
about where we're going think of it like
a foundation of a house why is the
foundation of the house it never changes
it provides stability and solidity to
the house now what's the house you
imagine building that's your Just Cause
and you can bend it and change it as you
go but you have a basic sense of the
shape of where you want to build it and
if the house blows down because of some
hurricane that comes you can easily
rebuild because you have a strong
foundation and it's still gonna say take
the same basic shape and this time it'll
be even stronger so sometimes stress and
tragedy and and disaster can actually
help make us stronger in ten
we're going through kovat and black
lives matter how does our society and
our lives become stronger because of
what we're going through we'll do a
couple more questions I think what else
I live from Switzerland Steph what do we
have here
[Music]
Anthony Henny oh so a company has
defined their just cause that's the
world we imagine what's next well as I
talked about in the infinite game it's a
good question because we've only read
chapters 1 & 2 so what comes next is the
rest of the stuff well now we have to
ensure that we're building trusting
teams if you're the leader we have to
study our worthy rivals so that we can
continue to get better and better and
better and better we have to prepare for
existential flexibility
hello kovat are we giving away all the
money at the end of the year are we
saving some of it just in case for a
rainy day and we have to have the
courage to lead which means is I'm gonna
build my business differently than
others even though everybody tells me I
have to be finite minded like there's
this fallacy we tell entrepreneurs which
is they always say pay yourself first
pay yourself first pay yourself first
really is that what is that what the
communication want to give to our people
that I'll take care of myself before I
take care of all of you
mmm that doesn't mean you have to
completely sacrifice everything of
yourself to take care of others there's
not martyrdom but it's about considering
the lives of others sometimes before
ourselves sometimes that we have to make
the sacrifices as leaders in order for
our people to feel that they matter this
is really important feel right this is
what listening is it's making someone
feel heard and these are skills and then
obviously to go back to the golden
circle you can have the why in the
inspiration you got to make sure you
have the values and the and the and the
process to help bring your Y to life and
at the end of the day what you do all
the tangible stuff has to
that that has to be a straight line okay
should we do one more
but we've answered that one already
hello the 60/40 Club Pam Dooley I think
we answered your question oh I like this
one how can we train ourselves to have
mindset or do it or do a check if we
currently act finite or infinite minded
there's no such thing as a perfectly
infinite minded leader there's no such
thing as a perfectly into minded person
there's no such thing as a perfectly in
tune minded organization it is a
striving it is an ideal and there are
times that we have to be finite minded
the question you have to ask is is this
a finite situation or is this an
infinite situation for example if you
have a product that needs to get shipped
if you're producing a podcast or you're
doing something it has to get out it is
finite there's a beginning middle and an
end and then once it's done you might
have something else to do but there's a
beginning middle and end which means you
play by finite rules to get it done but
you have to concept of the infinite game
think of it like a like a gate agent a
gate crew at a at an airline it's finite
there's a beginning middle and end we
have to get that plane off on time and
then it's done right but we don't want
them screaming and yelling at customers
just to get the plane off on time
because that's a finite mind it's a
finite mind set completely ignorant of
the infinite mindset we want them to be
aware of the infinite mindset which is
you have to treat people right so that
they will do business with us again
because only if they do business with us
again will our company survive and so
this is when sometimes you get
bureaucrats which is they hold up the
rulebook and say you have to do this
it's all a finite mindedness it's all
fine but we have to have we have to have
a concept of the of the infinite mind so
can you train infinite mindset
absolutely it's like I said before it's
about talking about it talking about it
talking about it sharing it talking
about it embracing it living it yourself
using it as a point of reference we do
this in our company now we say hold on
guys I think we're getting a little too
finite here and in this case we have to
be more infinite minded and we start to
think not what we're doing right now but
we start to think about the ripple
effects if I do this what will happen
how will that affect the people how will
that affect the product how a lot and we
start thinking all the ripples and
sometimes we make mistakes and we pull
back a little bit
but we're starting to think of ripples
now we we constantly are distinguishing
between the two as we do one more I want
to do one more let's do one more live
question perspective is the key yes it
is Oscar
you know remember this is Victor Frankl
stuff we cannot change the world around
us oh we can changes our attitude
towards it you know somebody asked me
are you a glass half-full or a glass
half empty kind of guy and I said I'm a
glass I'm a glass totally full it's half
full of milk and half full of air it's
completely full most of the stuff in our
world is about perspective you know I
remember I showed up late to a meeting
once and somebody said with a very
condescending tone you know Simon the
early bird gets the worm
and I responded and the early worm gets
eaten so you know perspective and I
think perspective is so so important
here because when you talk about who we
are and good and bad it's all contextual
so I've stopped thinking about our
company or even myself in terms of
strengths and weaknesses what I did
right and what I did wrong it's all
context and the story that I like to
tell is I'm disorganized I'm very very
disorganized and you know my mother used
to make fun of me when I was little that
if it wasn't attached I'd forget my head
probably right
and so you know as a young entrepreneur
I'd started this company I was 28 years
old and I would go to these networking
events and I'd meet these people they'd
go Simon we have to work with you I was
a young consultant I was a little
marketing consultant we have to work
with you I took their business card and
any organised entrepreneur would write
down the card put it in a in their phone
whatever it was and they would call the
next day they would email the next day
and say thanks so grace meeting you so
great meeting you
let's let's let's see if we can work
together Yahoo over here in the span of
getting the business card would lose the
business card and then nothing would
happen and I remember this one it
happened more than once but I remember
one like two weeks later I found a
business card at the bottom of a bag you
know covered in dust bunnies and I was
like oh probably should drop this person
a note two weeks after I met them and it
turns out they wanted to work with
even more because they thought I was
busy so is it a strength or a weakness
it depends it's the context it's the
context and so perspective is everything
everything requires context we don't
have strengths and weaknesses it all
depends on when we're doing it and where
we're doing it so on that note on the
note of perspective I want to thank
everybody for coming today
so much joy I have it what I really love
and what's really inspiring for me is
there's so much appetite for this
infinite mindset there so much appetite
for for us wanting to change this
mindset and learn to recognize it in our
world I think one of the things it's not
just about embracing it in ourselves but
learning to see it in others a lot of
questions were about what if my boss
what if my company is finite minded
simply our ability to recognize who's
playing with an infinite mindset who's
playing with a finite mindset helps us
navigate helps us be able to communicate
to speak in their language to help
advance the greater good right because
we have to be translators rather than
just simply a teachers so I think one of
the best things about learning about
these different perspectives these
different mindset mindsets is actually
learning them too is learning to see
them in other places and learn where we
want to navigate our infinite minded
lives so thank you for joining okay we
will be being that we will be back next
Friday July 17th same time 1:00 p.m.
Eastern for the next infinite game book
club same places will be on YouTube
Facebook and LinkedIn and we will be
covering chapters 3 through 5 so bring
your questions about chapter 3 through 5
and we'll talk all about them chapter 3
is caused no cause which picks up on the
just cause on how often we get it wrong
the keeper of the cause there's a
responsibility of someone and a group of
people to advance that cause and then
finally I the responsibility of business
and take on Milton Friedman himself so
that's what we're gonna be doing next
week will be a good one especially all
the talk about the responsibility
business if you want to send your
questions in advance send them to book
club at Simon Singh Kham if you want to
rewatch
anything here refer back to it or show
it to a friend who missed it the
recording will be available on YouTube
Facebook and LinkedIn you can see it
everywhere and if you want to dive in
further into these concepts and learn to
adopt an infinite mindset we've actually
but my wonderful team has started to
build coursework and actually how we can
learn to do these things some people
asked how do i how do i articulate my
just cause so we have some courses that
we're developing that we've developed to
help you do that there are live classes
I can't stress you know I'm a big thing
about human interaction so there are
live classes and because I love book
club we have a 20% discount code for
only four people in book club so if you
use the discount code book club rules
for the whole month of July you can get
20% off all the classes book club rules
is the discount code for 20% off we have
classes on how to advance a just cause
how to build trusting teams and how to
study your worthy rivals very excited
about those we'll be adding more classes
as we develop them thank you for joining
thank you for reading with me remember
book club is not about reading a book
book club is about doing things with
each other find one friend keep the
group together it's about the
discussions you have before our little
weekly book club meetings so take care
of yourself take care of each other and
I look forward to seeing you next week